why hello there
i'm dave rubin this is the reuben report
direct message
and today is january 20th 2021
is anything going on in your world
all right here we go people uh joe
biden's the president of the united
states
okay it's okay i know it feels weird
i know a lot of you watching this did
not want this to happen
i think some people thought a kraken was
coming here we are
joe biden's the president of the united
states we're going to go into a little
bit of the inauguration stuff
we're going to go into a little bit of
the
media coverage of the whole thing and a
few other things that i want to touch on
um but i want to start off with just one
thought and then
and then a quick story about trump and
then we'll
get into all that um first off my
thought is
is consistent with something i've been
telling you guys over the last couple
weeks
which is that you know if your whole
world view consists only of politics
you'll be wholly miserable i truly
believe that and that's why on a day
like today where the result
is not what i wanted it to be right like
you guys know about my political
evolution you know my
my belief system you know my political
positions on pretty much everything
i have a feeling a very bad feeling that
that what biden is going to usher in
uh is going to be against most of those
beliefs and against most of the beliefs
that the founders of america
really wanted i think we're ushering in
this really twisted
version of equity wrapped in social
justice
under the guise of tolerance that's
going to be very anti-american actually
and anti-freedom and anti-liberty and
anti-individual and all of those things
i accept all of those things i'm not
sitting here thrilled today
obviously but i also don't believe that
politics is the sum totality of how i
view the world
and i wrote about that a bit in my book
and it's one of the ideas that i've been
trying to talk to you guys about over
the last couple of months
because the people that endlessly think
about politics non-stop
are the ones that are constantly
hysterical constantly want to control
you
constantly want to tell you how to live
and i think the great challenge for
those of us
that are more liberty minded that don't
want to turn to the government for
answers on everything that want
a bottom-up view of government and not a
top-down view of government
our challenge is well if we want to sort
of live and let live and
get the government out of the way and
you live your life and don't kill
anybody and
don't steal and have some basic laws and
the way it was all set up
well that's just fine but if you have
this other set of people that are ever
encroaching on your rights and saying i
want more of your stuff and i want to
indoctrinate
people through public education and i
want to do all of these things that are
not in line with your views then it puts
us in a very tough position that's
something that we're going to all have
to think about over the next four years
and we're going to think about it hard
and we're going to have to figure out
ways to counter the ever encroaching
and giant mass federal government that's
just going to be getting bigger and
bigger and it's going to be aided by big
tech
and aided by mainstream media and the
rest of it so
that's going to be our challenge and
i just think that right now like on a
day like today i'm not thrilled
obviously like i do hope that maybe
everybody calms down a little bit i hope
that there's
some reaching across the aisle i hope
that there's some healing and i know
we're saying a lot of those words right
everyone's saying those words today
or the media is saying those words
because they got what they wanted or the
biden folks are saying those words
because they got what they wanted but of
course we know if it was the reverse
they would be saying burn it all down
they would be saying the dictator won by
the way the dictator
got in his helicopter and i think went
to his hotel in florida
they toppled the dictator he's you know
sitting at mar-a-lago right now eating
shrimp cocktail
they got rid of the evil dictator who
forgot to kill a lot of people and
didn't
get us into any wars anyway i just want
to uh
i wanted to say that because i know it's
it's sort of sucky
at some level if if you believe the
things that that i believe but i think
that there are
or not even if you believe the things
that i believe if you sort of ballpark
have a sense of the world that's similar
to to my sense of the world then
you're not thrilled with what's going on
right now but let's see
let's see and america has has had a 250
year
history of like you know we thought
things were going to be pretty terrible
and things maybe didn't turn out to be
terrible
we can still fight for what we believe i
get it with big tech
and there's like an extraordinary set of
problems right now
and two ideas um sort of socialism
communism
and and freedom that are really
intractable and and they're getting
sort of heightened by big tech and
algorithms and all that i get it it's
it's a lot of problems right like i'm
even a guy with a pen saying it so if
you're if you're a guy with a pen saying
something you know that they're telling
you something that's true
and it's like i get all that stuff but i
do think we can get
get past this if you want to hear any of
my other thoughts on it
uh you can you can join us at uh
reubenreport.locals.com where i'm
sharing ideas with people and people are
exchanging ideas and it's much more
pleasant than most of the other
social media things uh let me do a quick
ad for bambi and then i will get to that
trump story i wanted to tell you about
guys when you're running a business hr
issues can absolutely kill you wrongful
termination suits
minimum wage requirements labor
regulations the list goes on and on and
hr
manager salaries aren't cheap an average
of seventy thousand bucks a year
bambi spelled b-a-m-b-e-e was created
specifically
for small business you can get dedicated
hr manager
craft hr policy and maintain your
compliance all for just
99 a month with bambi you can change
hr from your biggest liability to your
biggest strength your dedicated hr
manager is available by phone email
or real-time chat from onboarding to
terminations they customize your
policies to fit your business
and help you manage your employees
day-to-day all for just 99
a month month to month no hidden fees
cancel any time
if you're like me then i know you didn't
start your business because you wanted
to spend uh
time on hr compliance that is absolutely
true let bambi help get your free hr
audit today go to bambi.com
ruben right now to schedule your free hr
audit that's bambi.comrubin b-a-m-b-e-e
dot com slash reuben and now back to the
uh yes so okay so everybody calm down
like
find your community find some
like-minded people
uh find your your faith or your church
or your temple
or or all of the other stuff that
politics seems to fill the whole of
and it never really fills that hole
which is why the the political people
you can get them to almost take any
position on anything so today is a great
win for democracy
but if trump had won the election it
would be a horrible day for democracy
you just don't want to be one of those
people it's a bipolar
existence not the way i how i want to
live i want to tell you just two quick
things on trump and then
we're going to move on and i'm going to
also try to talk a little bit
less about trump you know the media is
going to really need trump still they
need him to be evil
constantly and they need all of the
negative stuff
like he died for our sins they need him
to be like the negative thing that
always exists otherwise they'd have to
critique biden and they're obviously not
gonna
be doing too much of that and they also
know where the clicks are the clicks
will still be
trump um but i'm going to try to talk a
little bit less about trump and that's
not to say that trump didn't fight for a
lot of the things
that that i wish would have stuck around
you know even today they're getting rid
of the 1776 project
which uh was going to actually teach
patriotism in school
and i was at the white house uh in a
meeting for
the 7076 project actually i was just i
was a bystander in the meeting i didn't
get involved in any way
but i heard them talking about bringing
patriotism back and a love for america
back like nothing about racism
or anything else but biden already got
rid of that all right whatever
but just two quick things on trump
because i am going to talk about him a
little bit less but i'm going to always
talk about the ideas that i care about
um and and any movement and any
political party or anything else needs
to be bigger than one man
obviously um so two funny things on
trump so one
um you know i've told you guys the story
about how when david and i went to
mar-a-lago about a year ago and we met
trump and
he was very nice and didn't care about
gay or blah blah blah
but there was another moment that i
think maybe i discussed publicly once
but i can't remember
but i think it's worth just saying for
just just one
last time uh as the media just tells you
that this guy was hitler or whatever
um as we were sitting at the uh trump
was at that point sitting at the table
and melania was sitting there
there were two other people and i was
standing and then at some point trump jr
got pulled away and i had a moment i had
about three minutes with trump alone
and i started telling him this was just
when um bloomberg had just either
announced that he was getting into the
race
seems like another lifetime ago or he
was just about to get out of the race
sorry just about to get in or he had
just gotten in i forget which one
and i said to trump i was like you know
mr president my i think that
bloomberg is really just getting in
because biden's the front runner now and
they know he's going to get all the heat
and they don't want him to get the heat
because he can't deal with it
on the on the podium during the debates
so they just need bloomberg there for a
little bit
a little while so the media can focus on
him that that way they can drag bite
into the
to the finish line now i fully believe
that that is exactly what happened
the bloomberg campaign was a total joke
the media was obsessed with it for those
two debates remember and everybody was
attacking bloomberg the entire time
even though biden was the front runner i
get at this sort of like insider
baseball politics stuff
but anyway i say this to trump and he's
like
he's like you know that is kind of
interesting and then he put his hand
across the table and melania's hand was
on the table and he touched her hand
and he said honey honey what do you
think about this and then i told her
what uh what i said he had me repeat it
to her and i
i told her and and then he he looks at
the two of us he kind of looks at her
and looks at me he's like
ah he's like that's interesting but i
think it's just uh because he hates me
okay so it's sort of like a perfect
trump story but i tell you that not
because of the story or to tell you that
i think i was right about the bloomberg
thing
more so that he touched her hand and
called her honey and it was just sort of
a pleasant moment
and and the reason i'm even mentioning
that is because maybe all of the people
in media and politics are not
as big cartoonish clowns as we we
purport them
to be i think that is quite possible uh
and i'll i'll do my best to
going forward not make them all out to
be that thing
uh anyway let's talk about uh
what happened today which is the
inauguration of joe biden he's been
sworn in he is the president of the
united states
kamala harris is now the vice president
of the united states okay there's no
riots no
nothing's exploding everyone seems to be
okay there were a lot of soldiers out
there
dc was sort of a ghost town but
everything sort of seems to be okay
but i thought we'd start by showing this
clip from cnn yesterday this went viral
on the
the twitter machine there and i think
it's uh sort of
a perfect summation of what we should
expect for the next
four years from our beloved journalists
at cnn those lights that are that are
just shooting out from the lincoln
memorial along the reflecting pool
i look it's like almost extensions of
joe biden's arms
embracing america it was a moment
where the new president came to town and
sort of convened the country
in this moment of remembrance
outstretching
his arms extensions
of joe biden's arms hugging embracing
fondling america can you feel
the love oh god i mean that is i just
thought that clip there's a gajillion of
those trust me i could show you a
gillion
that's a lot that's a big number of
those type of clips of just these
slobbering
people and it's like all right that's
the way we're gonna do this the lights
across the pond he's hugging us
and lifting our butts and patting us on
the head
sniffing our hair it's just it's just so
sad and pathetic but we are gonna have
to get used to that and as i said
that's sort of why they will also need
trump they will need trump because no
matter what happens in the next couple
years when we go back to wars or
whatever it might be
they're gonna have to say well it was
because trump did this that or the other
thing so they need him to be the
perpetual
bad guy in the script right he doesn't
just get written out of the script now
he's now just the the perpetual bad guy
that they can always aim
the fire at and we're just gonna see a
little we're going to see
so much more of this it's nauseating um
anyway uh biden was inaugurated we've
got a couple
a couple images from uh what's going on
uh there was the capital lawn
um you know not a lot of people there i
get it social distancing
the pandemic although nobody's talking
about the pandemic anymore although
uh my governor here in california the
great gavin newsom tweeted out that
today he feels patriotic
which is sort of interesting thing for
him to say so for the last four years i
guess because he didn't like the
president he wasn't patriotic when he
was eating those fancy meals
at french laundry but he's patriotic
today still though keeping us in
lockdown it's 75 and sunny outside i
can't have a cup of coffee
with a friend outside or i'll be uh you
know dragged away
um but in any event that has nothing to
do with the inauguration per se
uh but yeah so we've got some photos
here uh that's the
that's the god it's depressing what else
do we got i think we've got
joe being sworn in oh there's lady gaga
goo goo for gaga gaga i mean the funny
thing to me about gaga putting aside i
mean lady ease up on the fillers
um is that she sort of was this like
born this way monster
different her whole thing was about you
being you be different and all she
really wanted to do at the end was just
like suck up to power
like just be one of the things in the
machine
anyway i don't particularly care about
the gaga but she sang
over there very nice she's just one of
us there's joe biden being sworn in and
that went off without a hitch so that's
good what else do we got here i think
we've got some others
uh yeah there's joe do we have anything
with kamala do we have come on we don't
have a kamala
kamala is smiling a lot um yeah she
oh and then of course the other issue
today is that
this is very exciting the national
anthem is back baby
okay uh everybody they sang the national
anthem they played the national anthem
everybody stood nobody nobody got on
their knees nobody got in trouble
we could be proud about america again it
was a shameful
place yesterday and for the four years
before but totally good now
and uh it's a it's a very exciting time
um
already what we're seeing obviously is
uh is biden is reversing a lot of
trump's executive actions he's doing a
bunch of his executive actions first day
in office they always do a lot of stuff
first day in office
um you know on the executive action
front this is exactly what i've
always said you can literally find
videos of me five years ago when i was a
progressive saying the same thing
that the true danger of executive
actions is the more that
we let the executive branch the
president who's just so
supposed to sort of set the table and
sign laws into existence not right laws
the more that we give that branch the
power to write laws well then what we're
going to be in
is in this perpetual state of four years
of this
four years of the reverse four years of
this four years of the reverse
and we'll just do that back and forth so
trump did a lot via
executive action i think a little less
than obama but somebody can fact check
me on that
um can we can we check that executive
actions of the last like four or five
presidents
let's just see um but the idea that
presidents do
so much by executive action is is very
dangerous and by the way
at some level you can't blame them
because congress is so
corroded and and stiff and and calcified
and nothing good really can come of it
and these people are not really working
for us they're just they're just working
so that they can become lobbyists
later and everything else uh all right
we're gonna get some numbers on the uh
on the executive actions in a sec
but in any event what you don't want is
the guy that's in charge to just do what
he want through the stroke of a pen so
it can be reversed by the next guy like
that that's not a good way to govern
and and it's a deeply dangerous way to
govern actually uh okay so i got some
numbers here so bill clinton did 364
executive actions uh george w bush did
291 so a little bit less
obama did 276 a little bit less and
trump actually did the lease
218. now i suspect it'll be interesting
to see what biden will be able to do
because you know he's got more power now
because of what's going on in
in the congress and senate we'll see if
he's able to just push more stuff
through legislatively
or they just won't care and they'll just
be like all right just do it with the
stroke of a pen
and and one of the things that i am
worried about is for those of us that
actually believe our founding documents
are good and that the constitution is
good and the bill of rights and the
separation of powers
it's like do these things and this is
something that michael malus said to me
a couple weeks ago
when we did that panel show it's like
these things exist
right like they exist and a certain
amount of people believe in them
but if the people that are in charge or
the powers that be don't believe in them
then then what
what use are they really beyond the the
paper
that they're written on like what they
they have to be living
meaning we're exercising the the words
that are written on the paper not living
in that we can just change them as we
see fit
um so it's going to be a little
dangerous
uh going forward we'll see how much they
do on that front but as i said
joe biden is president i don't want an
insurrection
i don't want violence i will keep
telling you what i think although
to get to the third story of the day uh
it might be a little more difficult
to tell you guys uh what i think and
what any sort of contrarian opinion is
because you can feel right now a major
move obviously big text banning a whole
bunch of people i just saw before i
got on here that there seems to be
another twitter purge of some fairly big
accounts today that's obviously not
surprising at all and everyone's just
going to complain about it and not do
anything about it and our
our congressman that you know they can
have some meetings every now and again
and you know they can get on c-span for
you jack you're a bad bad man there and
it's like okay well you didn't do
anything about it so whatever it is what
it is
but you can really feel a narrative
being being written right now being
scripted right in front of our eyes
that everyone conservative it's not just
oh
like they've tried to turn the trump
people they went from nazis to now
they're insurrectionists and terrorists
and no flylist
but now they're going to have to keep
widening that uh to conservatives right
conservatives or basically anyone not
woke which is why for years
i've been saying that it's all of us
versus the wokesters
that's all it is and i don't even think
there's that many of them they've just
they've usurped a tremendous amount of
institutional power it's just
it's actually quite incredible and
should be studied one day and you have
to sort of admire its elegance in its
evil
um but you will see a big push to cancel
anyone that is not woke uh and here's a
video
uh from cnn this is former facebook
insider alex stamos
talking about what should happen to
conservative media
we have to turn down the capability of
these conservative influencers
to reach these huge audiences there are
people on youtube for example
that have a larger daytime a larger
audience than daytime cnn and they are
extremely radical and pushing extremely
uh radical views and so it's up to the
facebooks and youtubes
in particular to think about whether or
not they want to be effectively cable
networks for disinformation
and then we're gonna have to figure out
the oann and newsmax problem you know
that these
companies have freedom of speech but i'm
not sure we need
verizon at t comcast and such to be
bringing them into tens of millions of
homes
um this is you know allowing people to
seek out information if they really want
to but not
pushing it into their faces i think is
where we're going to have to go here
oh the old they have freedom of speech
but
line yes so you you think that maybe
this guy who's a former facebook guy
you think that maybe facebook was
possibly i don't want to be a conspiracy
theorist
i don't want to get bad from youtube but
do you think that maybe they might have
manipulated some information over the
last couple years you think that that's
remotely
possible to stop the nazis and hitler
you think they might have done that they
might have done that yeah
but you can see what's happening here
they will try to craft the narrative so
that a t and t
the other cable providers so that
they'll drop channels like oann
or newsmax or whatever it might be it
does not matter what they're saying on
those channels as long as they're not
you know fermenting violence you know
direct calls to violence or breaking the
laws of the united states
they're allowed to have counter opinions
they're allowed to have political
thought that is
that is different than mainstream
political thought and the irony that
that somehow those dangerous right-wing
ones are the only ones fermenting
anything while we watch cnn and msnbc
for the last couple years literally
encourage violence chris cuomo talking
about nowhere in the constitution does
it say protest has to be peaceful
or don lemon calling half of america
white supremacists
or ali velshi on msnbc telling us that
these protests are mostly peaceful while
there's buildings exploding behind him
you've all seen the videos right you've
all seen the videos so it's like they've
they've fermented this stuff they've
poured gasoline
on this fire and now they want to make
sure that networks are taken off cable
tv and of course the one that
that sounded uh particularly
poignant to a guy like me is that he's
saying that there are
youtube channels that get more views
than daytime cnn
now first off he also then implies that
these are these are radical extremist
channels or whatever i'm not really sure
what channels he's talking about really
but there are people
that are getting more views that are
doing something remotely close to the
news which i would
assume includes a guy like me probably
includes
a guy like tim poole and there are there
are lefty versions and everything else
but what they're really saying is we
don't want competition
that's all he's really saying it's like
for all the times that i joke about cnn
and cnn is a
terrible news organization with all
democrats who are on air pretending
to be nonpartisan right wolf blitzer
obviously a democrat jim acosta
obviously a democrat jake tapper
obviously a democrat
brian stelter obviously a democrat like
don lemon obviously a democrat
uh chris cuomo obviously a democrat like
we all know it okay we all know it
right curtain man hello um we all get it
we all get it
uh but i can make fun of them all the
time and tell you what a terrible job
they do and that
that is the truth right that is what i
have come to believe
but i'm not calling for any of them to
be kicked off cable
despite spreading misinformation and
being partisan hacks they they can go
ahead and do that
and when i started this show i said this
thing about you know for those of us
that want to sort of live our lives
privately and care about our families
and local community
that the problem is we're going to have
this ever encroaching movement of people
who want to control
the way our lives are this is a perfect
example of that it's like well wait a
minute
i just want to do what i do here put it
out on youtube if you like it great if
you don't like it
don't watch zippity-dippity right nice
and easy but
if there's going to be a movement by
facebook officials to go on cnn
to pin everyone that disagrees with them
as radical
and an extremist or an insurrectionist
or something like that
so that they can get us booted off cable
channels or
get servers blown up or get us kicked
off youtube well then we
we got a real problem and that's what
these people are telling us
uh and i would also like to say and i'm
going to give props to the two
guys sitting in this room right now not
that i would dare have people in my
house
due to the orders of commandant newsom
uh
but my my producer michael and my
director connor uh
that's that's all we got for this show
the three of us sit for a few minutes in
the morning we discuss what we're gonna
do and we do it
and that is what they're really afraid
of they're afraid
that a slim trim profitable operation
that's totally independent
can actually affect things and change
things and clean things up and not make
people hysterical
and i'm super proud of that and i'm
gonna keep doing it now i'm feeling good
i was a little i was a little somber
at the beginning of this i'm feeling
real good uh all right guys
i'm on like a gajillion television shows
today that i assume are on networks that
maybe will be on the air by the time i
get there
uh and if you want to talk to me
directly we really i know i keep saying
it but we've got something so cool
happening
at the reuben report locals community
like we're cleaning up
social media it's different i promise
it's worth it
reubenreport.locals.com oh and this
friday we're doing
we're back to doing the panel shows on
friday and what i thought we would do
to mix it up is we're trying to get
three people that were at least loosely
affiliated with the trump thing
to to sort of figure out okay well what
happens to the
to the movement now sort of the america
first movement right now
so uh we have sean spicer on we have seb
gorka
and we're working can i mention who
we're working on no i can't mention who
we're working on we're working on one
more
stay tuned for that uh and i'm on sean
spicer's show today
uh so you can check that out on newsmax
assuming that facebook guy hasn't you
know
ensured that they've been kicked off
cable i'm on eric bowling's show i think
in about an hour and i'm on glenn back a
little bit later
today and i think maybe i'm going to
walk the dog so have a great day
everybody
it's all going to be okay god bless you
and god bless america
you